today while Sinjin has his interview at
the bar I have a doctor's appointment to
go over the x-rays on my foot in the MRI
on my knee all right thank you I'm
definitely not a hundred percent and my
life basically went on pause I have been
stuck for months it's frustrating that
it's such a long healing process so I'm
just hoping for the best how are you
today
good how are ya follow me up on the
table
yes please it's easier oh I thought that
I should have done that how you been
feeling um um definitely better with the
pen out of my foot good so if you don't
mind just go ahead and take off that
food Tonya came to me about three months
ago she had a very bad car accident and
had a severe injury to her right foot it
was essentially a crush injury so I had
to find those pieces of bone and then we
put a plate on it with several screws
holding that plate in position it's the
lining well it hasn't shown any
arthritis yet but after maybe two years
you'll probably begin to notice that
arthritis so let's go to your knee right
now so the MRI shows a lot of bruising
to the bone okay okay on both sides so I
really want you to stay with the therapy
for not just your foot now but also for
your knee okay okay but the strength
training and I'll see you back in about
six weeks how long do you think until
like I can start bartending again we're
looking at a minimum of 6 to 12 weeks
from now
[Music]